well welcome to Hannity yeah the crazy
Democrats exposed let not your heart be
troubled
breaking news multiple fronts tonight oh
the great one Mark Levin I just checked
in with him he is fired up and he will
be joining us tonight Laura Trump joins
us tonight so many of you have been
asking we have the history two days
after President Trump is elected
impeachment impeachment started all
through 2017 18 19 we got it all covered
we're gonna play the long version but
you got a tape it cuz we can't play it
every night it takes too long anyway
that's coming up plus mystery
surrounding the identity of the non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower who
kicked off this insane new Ukrainian
witch-hunt one report Paul Sperry real
clear investigations Real Clear Politics
claiming that a Trump hating deep state
operative with close ties o to Joe Biden
oh and Trump painter former CIA director
the corrupt Brennan and staffers working
for the compromised corrupt congenital
liar Adam Schiff shocking and Sperry
reports that he also has ties to the
very same DNC operative that helped the
Clinton campaign went to the Ukrainian
embassy to get dirt on Donald Trump and
his associates and coordinated and
colluded with Ukraine to impact the 2016
election now we are now looking down the
barrel of yet another national crisis
clearly orchestrated by the deep state a
hit job that will not go unchallenged
let me let me be very clear here tonight
because on this program now we're gonna
wait we always give due process
presumption of innocence we're not going
to reveal the person's identity that
everybody in Washington is talking about
until we can independently confirm the
facts that's just fairness
also breaking moments ago another star
witness in yes the compromised corrupt
congenital liar shift secrets Soviet
style impeachment coup attempt just
again obliterated Democrats narrative
that's why they're doing it behind
closed doors they're getting the crap
beat out of them every night I talked to
my sources another disastrous day for
Democrats and that's why they're staying
by
closed doors that's why they're using
the soviet-style impeachment proceeding
and Democrats are all giddy remember it
Lieutenant Colonel Ben man's
interpretation of the call but we don't
really need his interpretation well his
boss testified today and literally
obliterated and blasted his
interpretation and story out of the
water today and more importantly
destroyed the phony lie and narrative
that the mob and the media's been
pushing that the transcript was changed
top national security official yeah he
was the boss his name is Tim Morrison he
testified nothing illegal took place
during the president's call with Ukraine
quote I want to be clear I was not
concerned that anything illegal was
discussed he also interestingly said
that the public transcript of the
conversation accurately and completely
reflects the substance of the call wow
that blows the whole thing out of the
water and Morrison reportedly testified
that he was concerned the contents of
the call would be leaked to the media
shocking for pretty good reason because
only this president has already had
multiple conversations let's see what
Prime Minister's presidents heads a
state leaked this has not happened to
any other president so of course he was
suspicious you would think this
testimony from a key top official would
cause at least some of the so-called
moderate Democrats they they say they're
moderate to put the brakes on the
impeachment madness and psychosis and
rage against Trump but not a chance
because today despite Morrison's remarks
only two Democrats voted to give a green
light to the corrupt compromise and
that's who Adam Schiff is congenital
liar he's been lying to us for three
years Adam Schiff so with the exception
of one congressman named Colin Peterson
and Jeff Andrew we told you about last
night every other Democrat take a look
at that list those from swing districts
districts that Trump won they voted to
go along with this madness with zero due
process none a compromise corrupt
congenital liar leading the lawless
unconstitutional witch-hunt
many of the lawmaker
on your screen they all ran on a
partisan platform bipartisan platform
they want to reach across the aisle they
want to work together and focus on
fixing the I'm helping the lives of
Americans and some even said that
impeachment is a really bad idea
but they went along anyway when push
came to shove and their arms were
twisted by Pelosi and company and the
squad they caved every one of them take
a look it's about both sides being
willing to actually say we're gonna put
aside our right our political labels for
a minute and actually focus on what's
best for the you know we're Americans
first we need to be looking for
solutions right now in this country
bipartisan solutions when I get to
Washington I'm gonna do what John F
Kennedy said we shouldn't be looking for
the Democratic answer we shouldn't be
looking for the Republican answer we
need to be looking for the right answer
we need to work together Democrats and
Republicans I don't think it's that hard
I have always said to me I did not get
elected to spend the next 18 months on a
political process of impeachment words
are cheap they all folded they all lied
to their constituents because the people
you saw yeah they gave in to the
pressure they're con artists ed up
working for their constituents instead
they always told the party lying and
whatever Pelosi and the squad wants
they go to vote for that's why they all
caved and voted to give this incredible
impeachment obsessed compromise
congenital liar remember he has total
control that nut that lunatic that's
been lying for three years they did this
despite having no public access to any
evidence no hearings no transcripts
nothing no due process these were the
rules under Newt Gingrich during Bill
Clinton's impeachment what built Newt
Gingrich for did Bill Clinton the house
openly debated they held an official
vote the President had the ability to
call witnesses his attorney did submit
evidence build a case had a chance to
talk to every witness but the corrupt
compromised shift
he just has full complete veto power
like a dictator he can control the
witness list the rules the evidence and
nothing you can do no fair hearings no
ability to mount any defense no rights
to the accused in fact we don't even
know what the charges are and shift we
know why
to us for all these years psychotic
Trump hater is the judge jury
executioner and what is only a public
show trial designed to convince the
American people that the president
deserves to be impeached for what we
don't know we're told the majority of
witnesses had heard nothing wrong with
the call that we have the transcript -
but they're not going to be asked to
testify publicly wait watch and see
that's how corrupt he is and Pelosi is
this is Soviet Union style on steroids
and so far it's all been conducted in
secret by a guy that is a fact witness
and compromised in the very case caught
more lies than I could even ever count a
guy who's a totally compromised
individual himself because his office
remember we know they were coordinating
with the non whistleblower whistleblower
from the beginning now that's just the
fact we'd like to know what was said
where they met that he offer an attorney
did he advise to go to the inspector
general because like we said there were
reports revealing that this
whistleblower his name and identity was
anti-trump Pro Biden a deep state
operative friends with Brennan with a
pension for leaking on this program
we're gonna independently verify all the
information but what we do know already
is chilling partisan Democrat colluded
with shifts office we need to know what
happened that also this individual
supports Biden and work for the yeah
Brennan we're gonna learn a lot about
Brennan trust me we're learning a lot
about Brennan in the days and weeks to
come so Republicans now must demand
answers
they must demand to know the extent of
this person's contact with shifts office
they must demand to know if he abused
his power while in government they must
demand answers on his relationship with
Biden Brennan the DNC and while they're
at it I think it's time America needs to
now we're gonna have transcripts
released
I want the transcript of every call with
sleepy creepy crazy uncle Joe Biden
that's the guy that was involved in a
real quid pro quo in Ukraine we want
every call between Barack Hussein Obama
and Vladimir Putin after Obama promised
more flex
ability after his election I'd also like
the transcripts of the calls between
Obama and Iranian leaders leading up to
Obama making the dumbest deal in the
history of mankind and giving the
radical mullahs of Iran the chant death
to America death to Israel a hundred and
fifty billion dollars it's time now for
fairness we now need to demand those
transcript because what's fair is fair
right and regardless of the
whistleblowers true identity the ongoing
witch-hunt conducted by Schiff supported
now by all but two Democrats is only the
latest in what has been a three-year
lawless unconstitutional bitterly
partisan coup attempt they've never
accepted the election results nor did
they accept four separate investigations
that proved in spite of what they were
telling the American people there was
Trump Russia collusion and they ignored
the dossier of Hillary the whole time
the dirty Russian dossier devoid of any
justice totally detached from reality
Americans are fair-minded that I can say
tonight for a certainty they will see
this for what it is they will see the
corruption frankly this is the filthiest
and most repulsive raw political act
that in my thirty-one years of doing
talk radio in my twenty fourth year here
at Fox that I've ever seen just a few
months ago speaker Pelosi actually told
The Washington Post kind of ironic
impeachment is so divisive to the
country that unless there's something so
compelling and overwhelming and
bipartisan I don't think we should go
down that path that will divide the
country Oh
Adam Schiff said at the time if the
evidence isn't sufficient to win
bipartisan support for this putting the
country through a failed impeachment is
not a good idea he's doing it Jerrold
Nadler impeachment should not be
partisan its partisan because every
single Republican today in the House of
Representatives stood united and strong
against the psychosis and injustice and
the witch trial everyone as it turns out
Pelosi shift Nadler they lied again they
are major-league hypocrites on top of it
controlled by their radical socialist
base let me tell you how this is going
likely play out without any due process
at all the psychotic rage filled Trump
aiding Democrats will vote to impeach
Donald Trump and the president will be
vindicated in the Senate by probably
almost all the senators if not all of
them without due process now the US
Senate needs to send a very loud message
to their corrupt House colleagues and
teach them a lesson about the
Constitution if you're not going to
allow due process we will dismiss this
on day one so far that is every
indication will happen and the best part
is today we are one year and three days
away from the election that's right and
that means that we the American people
you the American people not Schiff not
Pelosi not Adler Nadler not the squad
not AOC you get to decide and you get to
reelect Donald Trump the people will get
their say now who knows what they're
capable of in the next year because we
know what they did before the last
election and after the last election but
the cold hard truth is anything between
now and November 20 to 28 is political
noise and political theater they have
done nothing for you the American people
they've done nothing
they have just tried to hate Trump
harder and harder every day and they've
been frustrated because they haven't
been able to get what they want but the
sad reality is Democrats the mob and the
media they're allies in the swamp
they've never sunk so low should be a
sad day for America I'm not so sad
because they think all they're doing is
helping Donald Trump they are becoming
by their actions the biggest contributor
to the Trump campaign re-election
campaign now they have completely and
totally detached themselves from reality
their sole mission surrounds this
irrational psychotic never-ending hatred
of President Trump the mere name of
which just triggers them all and by the
way there's also a deep hatred for We
the People the smelly Walmart shoppers
the irredeemable deplorable z' that
cling to God I believe in gargons our
Second Amendment rights our Bibles and
religion yeah there's a deep contempt
for America
now this vote by the way this is just
the latest coup attempt one middle
finger one more deranged scream and yell
from a group of people throwing a temper
tantrum because they lost and never
accepted the results of the 2016
election and will let down by four
separate Russia investigations they were
so counting on Robert Muller to do this
for them now they're gonna do it
themselves and make it up as they go
we'll have more on my monologue in a
moment first joining us with all the
details of what happens next in other
words the hitchhikers guide to this
impeachment coup attempt